Yankees come out like this you know how
Yankees always look so proper you know
they're gonna kill him why skip them are
so excited and in the game star then
it's three two what if everybody on the
SP is going crazy and three three and
then and number four four days in
October which is the story of the 2004
Red Sox that are down three to nothing
to the New York Yankees and they make a
comeback this has never happened before
the entire country was rooting for the
Red Sox because they hadn't won a
championship for a while since they
traded what Babe Ruth the whole thing
that they did all these guys are cursed
because it's the curse of the Bambino I
cannot believe they're going through
this now we got some insider information
about what happened with Kevin Millar
Kevin Millar the third baseman who was
not the top-five best player on that
team at that time Manny Ramirez had come
off the Cleveland Indians he was playing
with Joey Belle those guys at that time
they had Pedro Martinez which was
killing it Curt Schilling and he had the
blood on his leg
they had Papa who was just leaving Ortiz
was coming from Minnesota that all these
other guys that Johnny got all these
guys right but everyone had given up cuz
the Yankees you're just gonna come down
it had the stacked team they're gonna
get it
Morel the story here you don't have to
be the best guy in the company to rally
everybody sometimes it's just a guy that
comes to changes a spirit before the
game this doesn't make in a documentary
this is just insider information due to
proper investigation that we have here
with the company Kevin Millar pulls all
the players I said listen if we're gonna
lose we're gonna lose let's do shot a
tequila
everybody because a shot at a killer
before the game and they go out and he
starts going and talking to the news
guys the journalist says hey you look
like you already picking Yankees don't
pick the Yankees I'm telling you don't
pick the Yankees we're gonna get it
don't pick they pick the Red Sox and he
goes tellin everybody and they still
lose Yankees come out like this you know
how Yankees always look so proper you
know they're gonna kill him Weiss Kevin
Millar so excited and in the game star
then it's three two what if everybody on
the SP is going crazy at 3 3 and then
both they went for 3 and the Yankees
locker room they're sitting there like
what the hell just happened today is
such a great documentary for you to
watch with your team especially if
you're behind in your numbers and you
try to make up the numbers and you're
trying to inspire some people in your
company to be a Kevin Millar